hello and welcome to this video playing
a free bar here on the chest so we got a
what a petrol yeah I usually go with 93
but this is a decent alternative leading
to oftentimes an exchange variation of
the French if they go d5 my opponents
didn't Age 3 was a bit early but I mean
it's it's playable it's playable yeah c5
[Music]
yeah definitely definitely an option
form for him I'm just always think it's
it's more desirable to play c5 and you
can put the knight on to c6 but ok here
I'm quite quite happy with my position
what is going on here he wants to play
rook f8 Bishop f8 sorry rook f8 that
makes very little sense
I mean look f8m would make little sense
his plan looks quite um quite normal
huh what is that I wants to play but
should a six maybe
Oh ma'am not even sure but this should
be five for such a great idea huh he
doesn't he doesn't react to to it at all
okay I thought 95 would be a little bit
awkward
maybe it isn't it seemed
maybe it doesn't really pose such a
problem okay
interesting
so yeah that's really really an
interesting way to play not something
that I had on the radar at all so well
he I'm currently an exchange up but
there are many things attacked Wow
amazing
didn't pay pay attention to that idea
know he can actually take f4 and he's
got he's got two pieces then what the
heck what the heck I'm really stunned by
this development I mean you have to see
that like here this is already need not
very good for black I was actually
thinking I'm close to getting somewhere
real and then all of a sudden he has
this great great defense it's really
really strong
I really felt that is C 585 and all I
was kind of anti positional Amy and it
is a little anti positional but that's a
great we found this Knight takes d5 93
shot I should have just thought about
this for a moment to relief I mean I
don't have to take on the eight very
very badly played
yeah position has just lost him and just
lost him they can take on no I thought
this is versus right
I briefly thought you can take on h3
which is not true just mistake on my
part
you know black is close to winning here
but it still has to play the odds the
odds good technical move at least 94 a
sec just attacked me okay that was the
only thing that my position has its
favor favor something that I can play
for why's that b6 is a bit weak I
probably should have played g3 first and
push the knight back to g6 now that I
think of it
yeah no no it's it's okay again that is
okay again I get rook c1 in that
position is okay I mean not brilliant or
anything but I'm quite certain I'm not
totally lost anymore
[Music]
[Music]
just wanted to put pressure on d5 not
sure if it was great decision he now has
a very good he has it all covered there
any way to attack it again I can only
add from b5 him but it's tough to get
down
um I mean I can get there but he's got
night to see seven maybe it still poses
problems I'll take it now we still got
night seven now
see any way to improve here
okay what now we have to push him back I
guess
okay
is falling apart down with the with the
time lo the rook is often easier to play
and then minor pieces with no time
if it takes roughly seven I can also
just wrap the pawn no this is good I
didn't see that the knight can check up
unfortunately
oh okay Jade dome
yeah Jim there was a really really weird
game and I was extremely happy I mean
this pollution is great for white yeah I
mean a5 and and he he put his pieces in
a weird way and I just like here I just
have to stop for a moment and not just
automatically think he gave me just the
exchange it's a it's a terrible decision
to take only aid after this as we as we
see and I'm basically winning I didn't
see this and of course during when I
when I thought about this again that
Joan yeah it was terrible to take on y8
because then all of a sudden he's got
this and like it's in great shape now if
I just I just have to think I just made
this terrible mistake of just instant
moving yeah this is I mean he had a some
weird nausea I think the setup already
is not really great yeah as you the
engine confirms that it gives me already
quite a substantial edge and just say
the bishop is in a bed is bad on b7 and
after a 5 this is really ugly you don't
get rid of this you mean this is not
really something that helps you know it
leaves b5 weak I can it's just a tough
decision if I want to like let him take
or take myself it's something like this
is really good for what I've got he's
got this weak spots and you know this is
just wrong here it looks at protected
squares so it's a quite comfortable
position and this is weird yeah so I was
very happy with how it developed but
then I
and I made this terrible move and now my
position just sucks Bishop g5 is better
when I have it you know minus four is
kind of harsh it is really very harsh I
mean I know that I'm lost but he has two
pieces for the rock right and minus 4.5
Wow now it stunts with stunts then it is
that much
I mean loss time that that's that's
clear and that I'm that I'm that I
should lose this but like minus five or
something that was really really hard
assessment yeah here I was hoping again
that I can pose problems and Wow
so here 97 stronger yeah concretely I'm
winning winning a pound on with you okay
because when I was after Luke c1 I felt
I should be okay
the engine still says Black is totally
winning yeah maybe maybe I'm losing d4
in the long run
just I don't get it like what does the
engine give it says rook gives g6 rook a
897 Luke 85 you should be for this is
supposed to be winning from like yeah
maybe he wins all the pawns going to e6m
he might win all the pawns I'm still not
totally convinced I'm sorry really
I have no counter play with two rooks
here probably haven't I mean the engine
is great in such a position but I have
to say one one thing that is a little
bit irritating me is this the stock fish
ten and sometimes they have weird things
going on if they have a new version I
see lines here where before gets traded
against d5 and even that like this
position the engine says I'm totally
lost
come on no it's just not right
okay it wins before ok sorry I take it
back black wins your phone yeah yeah
maybe I mean the engine must be very
very very very reliable in such a
situation just like like minus two point
something is this harsh somehow but it's
probably this is the case yeah and here
round here we both had absolutely no
time and we're playing like playing on
the increment basically yeah I thought
also I thought it should be some some
should be equal and but when he gave me
this I should be much better I am yeah
no I am much better here there were some
mistakes and five was a mistake okay
yeah yeah that's actually instructive
like this one or where d7 that we should
come see that city has a fortress type
of quality very difficult for me to do
anything
hmm yeah yeah okay you you cannot really
judge any moves here too harshly we had
no time really so there's no wonder that
there were some some blunders an
instructive moment really is this one
where I made a terrible mistake by I
know not thinking simply and just take
if I just think for a moment then it's
kind of obvious that ninety three is at
least an option
yeah and when you register that the move
is there then you spot that it's just
bad it's just bad I have too much
hanging still a little bit shocked that
it's supposed to be - for something I
hear like - four is harsh but yeah
interesting game thanks a lot for
watching